greeting the store you [__] out
there in patreon Ville uncle Joey here
it's Wednesday the 22nd of July today
this morning I didn't make it do a
couple of [__] errands and I went to
the wheat store so I want to show you
what I usually get on the wheat store
but before we do that we'll smoke a
little number what the [__] we'll get
together we'll have a few [__] on our
eyes it's been a good week so far
physically emotionally mentally you're
swinging dick you got two good podcast
you're probably listening to back and
black we're getting ready for the
anniversary on Saturday who gives a [__]
what we're doing here is talking to a
pantry on what's happening you bad
[__] I've been busy all week
but today I got some time to [__] around
when you [__] I answered your
email if I give you some post my mind
what's in my mind everybody else gets
you know oh God you [__] I give
you something to think about every day
but talk to chief what do we get at the
weed store today got a couple little Jam
sources always
a little Kico moti there let me tell you
something
two milligrams [__] two three
milligrams of cbn melatonin Medellin
through your [__] legs like you
understand me
this is the teat if you have insomnia
right here okay this year they're
beautiful
Oh what do you [__] think about that
when I go to a week gotta [__] around
you understand me discover this [__] you
gotta go in and out you gotta stop up
for a week I got my wife go stay with a
little edibles to go to sleep she takes
these little [__] gummies and it's
night-night I ring it when I gave the
deed done ready other day if you can't
sleep and you don't smoke reefer these
kick them Oh [__] tablets look at
that
nothing
you eat or these and a couple [__]
tea and you put on something that put
you to sleep like for me it's gladiator
I put 20 and I think Lana is so many
times it's like a [__] to sleep I want
to go to sleep up but I'm gladiator 100
did my wife [__] back my wife put
this out for me buddy keys to remind me
to get a Hannibal today
that goes in the [__] trash
BAM there you go
knock yourself the [__] out there and
some [__] check this out here a
little confetti cake this will put a hem
in your [__] skirt adding a little J
for later see you know how we do it here
nice
it's Wednesday you're relaxed everything
is beautiful nobody's bothering you
you're getting unemployment a few more
weeks then after that we got to start
selling [__] trinkets on the side of
the road whatever [__] read palms I
don't give a [__] whatever house you
come up with you got to do what you got
to do that kids got to eat and you got
to keep the lights on I know you had